so good afternoon welcome to the
Macmillan Center I'm Ted
Dean of the Yale School of Management
Ian Shapiro director of the Macmillan
Center regrets that he's away from Yale
this afternoon
welcome to the coca-cola world fun
lecture Yale this lecture was
established in 1992 to support endeavors
at the intersection of international
relations international law and the
management of international enterprises
and organizations along with the
Macmillan Center the Yale School of
Management and the Yale Law School
joined in sponsoring this event
our featured lecturer was recently named
chief economic adviser to the Government
of India
he's one of of course the leading
experts on the global economy
he's also the Eric J bleacher
Distinguished Service professor of
finance at the Booth School of Business
at the University of Chicago in addition
he is a visiting professor for the World
Bank the Federal Reserve Board and the
Swedish parliamentary commission our
speakers previous experience with the
Indian government includes leading a
Planning Commission appointed committee
on financial reforms I recall that the
The Economist magazine when they
reported on the outcome said simply mr.
Rajan got it right our speaker was
formerly the president of the American
Finance Association and the chief
economist at the International Monetary
Fund the IMF our speakers research
interests are in banking corporate
finance and economic development
especially in rural finance plays in it
his papers have been published in all
the top economics and finance journals
he served on the editorial boards of the
American Economic Review and the journal
Finance he was awarded the inaugural
Fischer black Prize in 19 2003
for the top finance economist under the
age of 40 it was sort of a hands down
award by his peers his book fault lines
how hidden structures still threaten the
world economy one the Financial Times
Business Book of the Year award in 2010
he gives me full credit for that book by
the way in my old job I had asked Raghu
Rajan to give a talk at graduation and
he's so graceful he said that that was
the end he when he was thinking about
how to put put everything going on into
perspective that helped him think
through the outlines of his book I'm not
sure if that's true
but one of the basic tag lines from that
book that I think he's promoted is that
when you think about financial price
crises you should understand that they
originated in political crises is that a
fair fair insight from from this
wonderful book I would also recommend
his co-authored book with Luigi Zingales
entitled saving capitalism from the cap
from the capitalists I can keep going in
2010 he was featured on foreign policy
magazine's lists of top global thinkers
in 2011 The Economist poll ranked Raghu
Rajan by his peers as The Economist with
the most important ideas for a
post-crisis world titled that our
speaker is chosen for his lecture is
quote our capitalism and democracy
failing us the challenges facing the
post-crisis industrial world please join
me in welcoming today's featured
lecturer Raghu Rajan
thank you very much for that very kind
introduction and and yes Ted you were
the inspiration for that book certainly
by asking me to give that talk and and
often you know we agreed to do things
because it forces us to think which
hopefully you will see in this in this
lecture I agreed to give this talk
because I wanted to think about the
links between capitalism and democracy
and to think about what's what's
happening in the world now I haven't
gotten as far is in my thinking as I
would like there are holes which I'm
sure you will be kind enough to point
out as we go through this lecture but
what I want to do is is is talk a little
bit about what I think happened before
the crisis and what's happening after
the crisis and why there are serious
challenges in front of us today let me
let me get into this directly by by
saying what we've seen around the
industrial world is basically a bailout
following the crisis bailout of
financial investors sometimes a bailout
of banks a bailout of governments and
occasionally a bailout of industrial
companies and along with these bailouts
which bailouts don't seem appropriate in
a capitalist dog-eat-dog world right the
the weak should essentially weak
organizations should expire while the
strong survive and you shouldn't have
the walking wounded being carried around
at least in the caricature of capitalism
that's how it works and enlarged
bailouts are are not consistent with
that similarly what we've seen is a
variety of authorities that are
unelected
zooming power so when we need radical
change in in Greece we have a
technocratic government appointed when
we need radical change in Italy we have
a largely technocratic government
appointed and of course central bank's
by some count the ECB under Mario Draghi
the Federal Reserve and the Ben Bernanke
are helping hold up the world through
various forms of quantitative easing
so technocrats technocratic governments
are displacing elected governments and
so you know given these you might very
well ask the question is is capitalism
does it have D problems what about
democracy does democracy also have D
problems and of course when you couple
that with the growing anxiety on the
street anxiety which we've seen result
in some sort of street protests in in
Spain in Greece and the surprise there
is that thus far it hasn't been more
sort of a suppressed
louder but also the fear that things can
only get worse because we have enormous
levels of youth unemployment in this
country we have announced number of
households in deep stress because they
they underwater with their houses and at
the same time there is a segment of the
population in almost every country which
looks as if no crisis actually happened
which is earning enormous incomes which
is gaining from the rise in the stock
market and and seems seems pretty fine I
mean Mercedes Benz and BMW have had
their best sales in the last few years
post crisis so the question really is
are we going to see increasing pressures
and and are we going to see a change in
system and especially because there is a
sense across the world that we moved
away from capitalism but the capitalists
are still around
and it looks as if they've captured
policy to bail themselves out and one
could also ask given that Labour seems
increasingly put-upon given that it's
powerless are we going to see a reaction
a reaction because democracy is not
giving voice to those people at the
bottom yes we've had the Occupy movement
yes we've had we've had protests here
and there but nothing nothing big
nothing grand and and certainly nothing
which which suggests there will be
systemic change so um what I'm going to
argue is I mean given this preamble I'm
I'm going to sort of argue a little bit
against it saying the crisis itself was
not caused by elitist or corporatist
policies it wasn't so much that the
regulations were really skewed towards
the corporation's but in fact I would
argue that it had some populist
underpinnings an attempt to to spread
the gains more widely but but I would
all I will continue to argue that the
attempts to spread the gains backfired
and backfired because these were
short-term attempts not really
well-thought-out long-term attempts at
spreading or sustainable attempts at
spreading the gains which I think
there's a great need of and and as a
result our what we have is these these
policies backfire but they backfire by
hurting the very people whom they were
supposed to help and so we have this
dual economy where the elite across the
world are doing very well while the
people who were falling behind and were
ostensibly to be helped by his policies
are even worse off post crisis and even
worse off partly because many of them
are bearing the brunt of the
consequences of the debt that was taken
on to facilitate these policies but also
because these structural problems that
were making them fall behind to begin
with are still with us the fact that
there aren't good ways of employment
for a certain segment of the population
in industrial economies I think is still
a very big concern and so I would argue
that going forward
we have two problems as a result of the
crisis first there is this popular
perception that the elite have benefited
that capitalism has captured democracy
and as a result this is a very unfair
system and and capitalism can't work in
a situation where there is a widespread
perception that it favors the few that
mobility is small etc etc and we'll talk
about reasons for that so we need to we
need to combat this not just the
perception but the reality that in fact
there is a bifurcation of ways in many
industrial economies a way for those who
go to elite schools who come from good
families who have access to wonderful
jobs and a different way for those
who've never been to all these places a
way which typically leads down rather
than up so I would argue that to
strengthen capitalism and democracy and
I would argue both because I think
capitalism is stronger when there is a
vibrant democracy and democracy is
stronger when there's a vibrant
capitalism I would argue that to
strengthen both we need to restore
opportunity to the middle class and
that's something that we had to do
before the crisis it's something that's
even more important post crisis because
the the problems of the middle class
have in fact been worsened by the
policies that were in place before
crisis and the big question here is is
it possible to do this because the
fundamental reason for the decline of
the middle class is both technological
as well as as the effects of
globalization and increased competition
so to some extent to restore the middle
class without dramatic change changes in
social policy might imply a significant
amount of intervention and the question
is can you do that intervention while
retaining the essential characteristics
of capitalism and democracy and I will
leave that as a question it's something
that I haven't
being able to think through there are
dangers that in fact it's not possible
and and and you may actually end up with
with something which which looks very
different from where we are now okay
that's where I'm going let me start
first with which sort of what I think
are the macro underpinnings of the
crisis I mean this simple view of the
crisis is really bankers inflicted pain
and suffering on the rest of the world
and I think there is some truth to that
but I think it has to be set in a larger
context why do the bankers suddenly
become greedy after all self-interest is
at the heart of economics are you know
and and if we don't have self-interest
we don't get much action so the real
question is what were the circumstances
under which credit became sort of unruly
and created the problems that we see and
I would argue you have to go back
perhaps even to the post-war growth that
occurred in industrial countries it was
extremely strong as you can see from
these numbers the US grew between 1950
and 1973 at an average of two point
seven seven percent a year Europe grew
at four point seven seven percent what
was behind the strong growth it was one
the fact that we actually were
recovering from both the depression and
the war the war created extreme
destructions of construction in Europe
added to the growth the fact that the
depression led to bad policies trade
trade destroying policies also created
the conditions for post-war growth just
restoring trade was very beneficial in
addition to that they were enormous
there's an enormous rollout of
technologies remember today we see the
internet and we say wonderful this is
this is this is a great intervention
this has changed our lives but the lives
of our grandparents were perhaps changed
even more by the kinds of innovations
that happened 40 50 years ago
electricity the motorcar are the
aeroplane and many of these innovations
hand been rolled out
certainly they were invented in the
early part of the
a century but rolling them out across
the economy really happened in a big way
post-world war so widespread
electrification of Europe for example or
the rolling out of of transportation
technologies so there was immense growth
from plucking these low-hanging fruits
in the in the in the words of Tyler
Cohen and economist from Virginia and in
addition to all this there was education
the increases in education in the
industrial world helped also create the
growth that that we saw over this time
so lots of growth seeming never to come
to an end at which point politicians
love to spend and they spent that growth
in the 60s the welfare state was in many
ways created and bolstered of course we
got Social Security during the
Depression but the other underpinnings
of the welfare state in the United
States came with Lyndon Johnson's Great
Society we saw that happening also in
Europe in a big way so promises to pay
for people's old-age promises to pay for
health care all these were augmented
during the mid 60s and during the period
of strong growth but in a pure as if it
would never come to an end and it bought
labour peace it bought labour peace
these were the years of plenty and then
it stopped in the early 1970s we had the
oil shock
we had productivity falling tremendously
and you can see both in Europe and in
the United States things came down
substantially over this period of the
post 1970s period I think the two
economies had different approaches
different reactions I'm going to treat
the UK as as in the same camp as the
United States what the US and the UK
United Kingdom did in response to the
slowdown was essentially deregulation
whether it's Margaret Thatcher or
whether it's Ronald Reagan it's open up
create growth through greater internal
competition create growth through
opening up the economy to external
forces competition
creates at least for a while more
innovation more more efficiencies and
that created growth and you can see that
the u.s. grew faster than Europe over
the spirit through these kinds of I
should say the the u.s. fell less than
Europe during this period what
continental Europe did was instead of
instead of you know doing reforms
opening up the economy to more
competition it focused more on
integration let's build a bigger Europe
let's build an integrated Europe and
thereby we will get more competition but
we'll also get a bigger market and
within that bigger market our companies
can flourish become stronger and that's
the way we're going to grow and again
that was a different approach that was
also initially moderately successful the
problem however was each of these
approaches created sort of limits and
and and in the u.s. the deregulation
certainly was very beneficial in terms
of increasing growth but it also in a
sense skewed the returns from that
growth towards the more talented the
more innovative the more educated and
one way to see this is to see the
financial sector in the United States
okay this is a picture from work by
Phillip Owen and reshef where what you
see is the Green Line which is the
relative education in the financial
sector okay and you see the relative
education of employees in the financial
sector was very high leading up to the
1920s and the great crash in 1929 post
the 1920s as you get into the 30s and
massive amounts of regulation in the
financial sector limiting competition
etc you see that smart and talented
leaving the financial sector relative to
the rest of the economy the financial
sector essentially goes down in terms of
talent goes down in terms of wages
relative to the rest of the economy
until the 1980s when you get the Reagan
era deregulation again
and again people start flocking to the
financial sector and the small are the
the better educated guys go into the
financial sector the relative bails who
goes up that's what I'm I want to
highlight the fact that greater
competition greater innovation also has
an effect on the distribution of income
that it is quite possible that excuse
the distribution of income towards the
more talented the more capable and so
what problems does that create well it
creates the kind of problems that that
we see emerging for the middle class
today so in addition to the deregulation
and the competition is the fact that
that also creates the space for new
technologies to come in new technologies
it also take creates a space for global
competition to come in so add global
competition new technologies on top of
the desire to be comparative and you get
the consequences on jobs that are
outlined in this particular graph so
think of jobs is divided into skilled
jobs and unskilled jobs okay that's the
y-axis and on the x-axis routine jobs
and non non routine jobs so what's a
skilled routine job the guy who used to
work in insurance companies basically
had a high school class education had to
know how to add and subtract both sides
of the band she'd had to know what went
on this side what went on the that side
had you know pretty good reading skills
etc and basically got a middle-class
income with good benefits that guy has
been replaced by a machine or a computer
long ago okay that job no longer exists
take the other version of routine jobs
routine unskilled jobs are the
mechanical work that a textile worker
does okay that job has been outsourced
long back forced to Japan then to Korea
then to China and most recently to
Vietnam and Cambodia right so anything
that was routine has either been quote
unquote globalized that's a bad word but
you know what I mean or has been
placed by technology okay that leaves
the non routine jobs which consists of
non routine skilled jobs the kind of
jobs that many of you will do will
aspire to do at this point
creative jobs and the non routine
unskilled jobs basically the work of a
gardener which we can still not
substitute with a robot the work of a
hamburger flipper you can't do that
still with a robot okay so we've got
this bifurcation and yesterday I was on
a in a meeting with one of the people
there was Marc Andreessen who is the guy
who founded Netscape some of you will
never would not have heard of Netscape
it used to be what existed before
explorer Explorer 8 it's lunch but
Netscape had perhaps the biggest IPO at
that time the equivalent of Google Marc
Andreessen had a very way very nice way
of putting it I think he exaggerated but
he says the world is increasingly being
divided into people who tell a computer
what to do and people whom the computer
tells what to do right so there are two
kinds of people now and the people who
tell the computer what to do are people
up there actually I would modify that by
saying people who tell the computer what
to do software
he's software he likes to be in that
category because there are people who
use the computer to improve their
creativity the people who use
computer-aided design the doctors who
use the computer to access large data
bases which allow them to give a better
diagnosis to the to the individual so
people who use the computer versus
people in a sense who take instructions
and and I think what that does is
because it bifurcates the economy into
high end jobs and very low end jobs but
the middle which used to be that left
upper corner has essentially disappeared
disappeared okay now that doesn't
necessarily mean we should have income
inequality it doesn't mean we should
have income inequality all it does mean
is that in industrial countries
a lot of jobs at the higher end and
people will aspire to get those jobs
right and yes there'll be some lower end
jobs but if enough people go into the
higher end jobs it'll raise the wages
for lower end jobs there's no reason why
a gardener who does hard work should be
paid less than the consultant except
that we have relatively few people
educated to the level that the
consultant needs and that's really
what's happening in the United States
the supply of skilled people who have
the right skills is falling behind the
demand for those people in the in the
words of Claudia Goldin and Larry Katz
from Harvard in the race between
technology and education education is
falling behind one way to see this is
look at male education graduation rates
from high school or male graduation
rates from college they basically
haven't moved much over the last 2025
years for the population as a whole
there is a skill mismatch even the guys
who graduate from college typically tend
to take liberal arts courses rather than
science technology engineering math
which is primarily where the jobs are
I'm not saying in any way and don't get
me wrong that liberal arts is a bad use
of of your college money or whatever I'm
just saying that in terms of where the
action is Marc Andreessen is probably
right there's more action in people
telling the computer what to do and and
therefore science technology engineering
math and of course if you want to change
this if you want to get more people to
be educated to the level that the
economy needs it needs an enormous
change not just in colleges which are
pretty good in the United States leading
the world in their quality it's it's it
means changing the nature of schools it
means changing nature of families and
family experience and increasingly
though what you see in the United States
is a bifurcation along every one of
these dimensions schools public schools
used to be the great equalizer no longer
charles murray has done has written a
very alarming book growing apart where
he focuses he serves abstracts from race
by focusing only on
white families and looks at the
experience of white upper-class families
versus white lower-class families in the
United States and sees enormous
differences in everything ranging from
incomes to lifestyles - you know divorce
rates are - in fact according to an
article in New York Times the other day
even life expectancy and that is really
alarming that there is a bifurcation
going on in the United States between
the top end and the lower end another
way of saying seeing this is are these
graphs by David autor from MIT where he
shows that over time look at the Left
graph are see skills arranged in
increasing order of skill on the x-axis
and what you see is in between 1979 and
89 what happened was the higher skilled
jobs got more people in them okay so
that's what that graph says more jobs
for the higher skilled jobs fewer jobs
being created in lower skilled and then
what you see is since then you see
something which looks more like a
u-shape when you aggregate these numbers
that is there are more jobs being
created at the lower end and more jobs
being created at the upper end and the
middle is shrinking considerably again a
reflection of that earlier graph that I
put out and you can see that also
reflected in wages the middle wages are
coming down wages at both other extremes
are going up and finally this is a third
way of showing the same thing
what you see in the dark line here is
the 9050 log hourly wage differential
the wage difference within the 90th
percentile of the income distribution
which is somebody who has a college
degree and the fiftieth percentile of
the wage distribution which is typically
a high school graduate who's a factory
worker you see that has been increasing
considerably even though the difference
between the 10th and the 50th percentile
between a farm worker
the factory worker is actually narrowing
so in a sense the middle is getting
squeezed out wages at the bottom are
increasing somewhat where's that the top
are increasing a lot the middle is
actually falling and falling out now
what one should there's not everything
is not bleak in what has been happening
there are actually some some some points
of light one for example is the new
elite the guys at the upper end are the
educated elite right they there because
they got a stronger education they're
not there because necessarily our family
wealth so if you look for example at
CEOs CEOs increasingly come from outside
the Ivy League not good news for you
guys but but they do increasingly come
from outside the Ivy League's they
increasingly are more educated but the
background is is not is not as elite as
it was however to some extent the CEOs
reflect what happened in the 40s 50s and
60s right when when things were much
better since then things are getting
more skewed and today it's increasingly
likely that the children of the rich are
much more likely to complete college
than the children of the poor and that
difference has been increasing in other
words even though we are seeing at the
top levels the effects of the
egalitarian education that prevailed in
the 40s 50s and 60s going forward we
increasingly go and see the bifurcation
and we'll have a new elite but the new
Elliot will be composed of guys went to
college and their children and the and
the new underclass will be those who
never had a chance okay so why is any of
this interesting it's interesting
because I think it affects the policies
that got us into trouble and going
forward it will affect the nature of
democracy so first in terms of policies
well if you had this kind of bifurcation
people falling behind and it's been
happening for 25 years there is immense
pressure on politicians to do something
okay and I would argue that the rising
inequality and the political pressure to
do something had two consequences one is
everybody started talking about
education since Gerald Ford
every president has been the education
president but of course it's very hard
to do something about education when in
fact there are deep underpinnings across
the board that drive it so if you can't
tackle that and if your horizon is
relatively short-term as a politician
perhaps you might come to the conclusion
that since I can't actually fix the
incomes is there any way that I can make
them happier better off because
democracy has these populist pressures
also if you figure out that people care
about consumption ah why not provide
them consumption and the easiest way to
provide in consumption especially when
you have limits on doing welfare
remember America is also going through
the reagan clinton era at this point is
credit if you can give cheap credit and
people can go out and use that credit to
consume especially if they don't think
that using that credit they're going
more into debt well that's basically
something which can make them happy it's
something that can make the bankers
happy it's something that the
politicians love nobody is made worse
off at least in the short run through
credit so I would argue that that if you
look at the consumption boom that we had
through the 2000s it was fueled by a
variety of policy measures as well as a
variety of private-sector measures but
the bottom line is given the pressures
on the politicians there was absolutely
no incentive to stand in the way any
regulator who tried to do something
about it was quickly reined back because
there was immense pressure for this
credit to go on and of course there were
large-scale programs in the Clinton
administration this was the attempt to
get affordable housing to broad segments
of the population and they were measures
taken we can discuss those in the Bush
administration it was a continuation of
the same policies but with the idea that
by doing so you would create an
ownership society create people who own
homes and therefore had an interest in
the future even though you know from an
income perspective it didn't look as
good and of course one could argue about
the extent to which these were used
our instruments that the government had
the FHA Fannie Freddie
coupled with the willingness of the
private sector to sort of jump on for
the right and you had a massive credit
boom so I am arguing is that the
fundamental sort of sources of the
credit boom in many ways are rising
inequality and immense pressure to do
something about it pressure to do
something about it in the short run
rather in long run and that typically
led to much more accommodative
government policies both on the
regulatory front as well as the fiscal
and monetary fund which led to the kind
of boom that we had and eventually the
day of reckoning the busts that we see
and and what you can see just bolstering
my point is that even though income
inequality rose over this period that is
the dark dashed line consumption
inequality did not it was much flatter
and some work by colleagues at the
University of Chicago basically show if
you look across the United States
across the areas of the United States in
areas with greater income inequality of
this period you had much more spending
by lower-income people in an attempt to
keep up and in fact they went into
greater debt and now those areas have
greater distress so the link I'm trying
to draw is between the financial sector
and the real economy the political
pressures to do something in a democracy
very natural pressures very important
pressures but unfortunately pressures
which result in short-term outcomes
which could be detrimental in long-run
the same guys who went out and borrowed
against the house as an ATM when the
price was going up are also people who
are deeply underwater today because not
only have they lost their jobs in those
areas but also their houses are now
worth 30 40 % less than when they bought
them so I would argue that that the
policies engendered by this inequality
were problematic so was deregulation of
failure in the in the UK in the in the
United States I would argue no it helped
the household as a consume and one of
the important effects for example is
Walmart Walmart has brought down the
price of the consumption Bach basket
especially for lower-income people
tremendously and Walmart of course uses
technology and globalization as much as
any other entity in the world
so deregulation could have worked if it
had been accompanied by the the things
that the government needs to do which is
skill building in a way that would keep
the incomes of of households strong
Financial Regulator financial
deregulation also was not a bad thing it
helped innovation but the financial
sector went off track so broadly when
I'm arguing is we didn't have a failure
of capitalism but we had a failure to
support the things that capitalism needs
that is reasonable regulation but also a
nurturing of the skill base of the
economy so it can take advantage of the
benefits of capitalists so what we're
left with is can we harness finance but
also can we do something to bring the
people who are falling behind back into
the economy in a reasonable way a way
that that gives them a chance to to
compete and on decent incomes and I'll
come back to that in just a second let
me for a brief minute talk about how the
euro area responded the euro area didn't
deregulate as sharply and as quickly as
as the United States ah they were much
more willing to protect industry to
protect labor but what they did instead
was integrated so that that created
competition between sort of national
champions
and the the problem however was that
there were limits to the benefits of
this integration without the deeper
underlying labor market reform making it
easier to hire and fire workers and so
on which the United States and the
United Kingdom had and so what you had
in these economies were what are called
insider/outsider economies economies
where if you had a job it was great
because you got a wonderful salary you
could rarely be fired ah and you really
had to do something terrible to get
fired in these places so the insiders
had it really good but if you were a
young person on the outside who still
hadn't got a job it was terrible
because you were large likely to be
unemployed and you were unlikely to get
one of those cushy jobs until some guy
who already had it retired in the
meantime you probably worked in
temporary jobs and and not really
anything with any decent benefits now
what happened in the euro area is once
they saw the limits of that kind of
integration they decided to go even
further and this was the move to the
euro which was a common currency and the
idea was with a common currency will get
even stronger competition will get even
more of the benefits of integration they
got that but they also got a common sort
of economic area with a common interest
rate and a common currency and because
the interest rate that they got in that
area was in some cases too low given the
nature of the economy it was common
interest rate given the state of the
economy given the conditions of the
economy what it resulted in was debt
fueled spending booms across the
periphery of of Europe you are a housing
boom in Spain yet local government boom
in spending in Spain airports ports
being created theatres magnificent
structures that now lie empty because
they spend too much in Greece
the size of the government increased 20%
after euro accession somebody was
telling me about a visit to Greece where
you know originally they had to go
through two officers to get to the Prime
Minister's office now you have to get
through seven offices because those
seven offices are manned by hanger-ons
who really don't have much to do so they
have an office and they interrupt your
progress to the Prime Minister but but
but you have to spend time on the way so
lots of of inefficiencies generated but
supported by the ability to issue debt
and of course this party went on until
it became impossible to issue more debt
and that's where a much of of peripheral
Europe is but they they are with an
additional complication in the same way
as US households
ended with a huge amount of debt these
guys have a double problem not only have
they ended up with a huge amount of debt
borrowed during the go-go years but they
also have economies which are terribly
uncompetitive because in the go-go years
the spending went without thought for
productivity and competitiveness
especially because the areas where the
spending was most extreme government
spending as well as in the construction
sector on sectors that are subject to a
lot of competition so you could increase
wages or you could increase them
substantially without much thought for
productivity now that nobody is willing
to finance them they find that in fact
they are highly uncompetitive and they
have to adjust and so that's where we
are we are in a situation where the
countries that liberalized the
deregulated have one kind of problem
which is extreme levels of inequality
sort of coupled with the with the
effects of the housing bus still in the
United States the countries that did are
integrate but then deregulate as much a
number of those countries are laboring
under deep problems of uncompetitive
nests where they have to get back on
track and become more competitive and in
the meantime both sets of countries have
increased borrowing from endlessly and
are weighed down by tremendous amounts
of debt and in terms of Europe again the
policies of allowing more boring by the
government's by the local governments by
the banks and by the households has
again ended in tears Europe started the
periphery countries Greece Italy and
Spain started the accession to the euro
in 1999 with high levels of unemployment
in 2007 before the crisis brought down
the levels of unemployment tremendously
in 2010 they're back to where they were
in fact they're little worse off and of
course now there's the threat of
government collapse etc so to answer the
question I started with has capitalism
subverted democracy I would say it has
we looked at in a more nuanced way
democracy created pressure to keep
growing and the
wrote the attempt to grow faster than
was sustainable was was made possible
through populist policies easy credit
government spending private financials
were not blameless in this process they
jumped on for the ride and essentially
may have written the the process too
long
there was a convergence between business
and politics here but to argue that the
crisis is a consequence of elitist
policies in the first place I think is
to miss read what happened that it was
actually in some ways a response to
broader needs and those needs are still
unmet our whether it be in the
underclass in Europe or the underclass
in the in the US this is a sort of just
an argument saying even the bailouts I
would argue that bailouts weren't
necessarily are meant to just bail out
the elite though when you look at them
they do seem that way saving the banking
system was important for the United
States if you had let the banking system
go it could have been disastrous now
could the bank bailouts have been done
in a better way
imposing more pain on the bankers
imposing more pain the shareholders on
the bondholders of course with hindsight
even with foresight it could have been
done much better but was the essential
scheme of saving the banks important yes
because otherwise what would have been a
Great Recession could well have been
converted into a Great Depression um I
would argue that the kid gloves with
which the financial sector was treated
was primarily because of cognitive
capture rather than because of crony
capitalism it wasn't necessarily because
the people in power in Washington wanted
a job in goldman sachs after they
retired or had a job in goldman sachs
and and and and loved the amounts they
had made and love their friends there I
would argue it's more that they talk too
much to people at Goldman Sachs while
they were devising the rescues that they
saw things from the perspective of the
big banks on Wall Street and didn't
think about the alternatives or had
gotten accustomed to the view that
baling these banks in the most in the
quickest way possible is the way to a
full fledge rescue and and perhaps could
have thought a little differently but I
would argue therefore that those
bailouts aren't necessarily a evidence
that we have got a lot of crony
capitalism there is crony capitalism in
every country there is crony capitalism
in the United States but whether it's
increased tremendously in recent years I
think one could debate we have large
deficits not because the banks were
bailed out that is a small part of what
is happening we have large deficits
because revenues are lower because
spending has increased including on
automatic stabilizers but also on the
stimulus so so I would argue that's not
a reason to say the capitalists have
tremendous influence and more generally
if you step back and think about the
democratic process you have to believe
the democratic process is more vibrant
today then it used me in the past
anybody who has access to the Internet
can start a blog fact my son has a blog
and writes repeatedly about how he
dislikes various candidates I won't say
which side he favors but but the point
here is that anybody can write you can
have access to public influence very
easily so yes citizens united give a lot
of power to the corporation's to the
unions but to some extent that bar has
been balanced by competition between the
large organizations last I saw President
Obama is generating more from these
super PACs than then prey then candidate
Romney and one could debate who has the
edge going forward so I would argue that
that really it is strengthened our
democracy to have much more
dissemination much greater sources of
information so before you accuse me of
being Pangloss IAM before you accuse me
of saying everything is fine I would say
there are still deep problems and those
deep problems stem from what was
unresolved before the crisis this
growing divide if there is a growing
divide and the majority is falling below
and that majority doesn't see
the opportunity or the gains from an
integrated global economy with
tremendous improvements in technology at
some point that in that population
falling behind will start protesting
okay when and if they start storming the
barricades I don't know but it seems to
me untenable that any democratic society
can maintain high levels of inequality
without the pushback eventually coming
because eventually the social contract
starts breaking down eventually the
capitalists get be legitimized how come
you're there while I'm here and how come
I have no chance of getting there the
capitalist system is supposed to provide
you a ladder to get there that becomes
delays demise but I think equally
problematic democracy itself starts
coming under strain when the big
capitalists are the owners of money
parcel to speak are basically get D
legitimized then they have no
independent influence on government may
take Putin's Russia if you're an
oligarch and you stand up against
government you get put in jail for a
long long time at least that's the
caricature of what happens there's
probably some truth to it
so which oligarch stays in Russia and
stands up against the government other
than you know as a put-up candidate by
the government very few so in that kind
of world there is no check or balance
against the government because large
concentrations of power outside the
government have essentially been DJ
legitimized and become dependent on the
government for their continued wealth on
the other hand in the United States you
have somebody like Sheldon Adelson
Adelson who is willing to run full
full-page ads against the government I'm
not going to take a stand on whether
he's right or wrong only the fact that
he exists is something that is a
testament to the possibilities in this
country of people with lots of money
standing outside the government and not
kowtow into the government that creates
that helps I think foster a stronger
democracy because it is one additional
constraint
arbitrary government so my sense is if
this increasing inequality are persists
we are going to get a deal atomization
of both the capitalist as well as
democracy and it'll be to the detriment
of both so we do need to restore
opportunity and hope to the middle class
and I think clearly we have to focus on
Education and Skills clearly we have to
improve innovation these are hard these
are hard but there is no shortcut to
this I think we have to work very hard
to do this and importantly this will
require some resources clearly we can
spend better but it will also require
some resources and the key question here
is how do you get the working rich the
guys who've made the money on their own
or presumably they see it as their own
to pony up for the kinds of changes that
need to take place and at the same time
how do you keep the policies of the
government from getting overly focused
on taxation and redistribution to the
detriment of innovation we need a
balance between both sides and that's
the difficult challenge going forward
and of course there are also immense
short-term problems how do you get the
unemployed especially the youth into the
labor force what kinds of ways do we
have of getting not you guys I'm sure
many most of you or all of you will get
wonderful jobs when you leave it's the
guy in the ghetto who's who's been
condemned to live there how do you get
him into a functioning job those are our
important important questions we need to
ask how do you how do you talk to a 57
year old GM worker who's been laid off
three years ago and has been looking for
a job in the auto industry but has no
hope of getting it because his skills
are way outdated ah what do we do for
those guys who are not too old to retire
not not too old to retire but not too
young to retrain themselves how do you
engage the unemployable the guys who
don't have the skills to cut it because
there will be some of them
how do you engage them and how do you do
this in Europe where the government is
increasingly hamstrung by high levels of
debt so that's where I want to end our
our problems are not elite capture at
least not anymore than the past I'm not
saying there is no crony capitalism I'm
not saying that policies aren't
structured to benefit the incumbents in
the industry there's always some of that
I'm just saying that what we've seen in
the recent past that led up to the
crisis was not that I think more of it
was populist policies across the
industrial world populist policies which
had democratic rules and were important
to assuage pain unfortunately they have
failed and with the electorate's
impatient as well as divided I mean we
talked about polarization amongst
politicians in the United States and
that's very real even according to
measures developed by political
scientists but that polarization
reflects the polarization of the
electorate and so it is very difficult
for politicians to break from the
natural constituency's and bridge the
gap between them and other politicians
so we had short term policies which have
made things worse our end and if we
extend that to blame the capitalist we
could reduce an important check on
arbitrary government what we need is to
work together in some sense to restore
our opportunity to the middle class now
the Bleak vision of the future is it's
impossible the bleak vision of the
future is technology has totally
displaced the middle class or
globalization will displace whatever
remaining jobs there are in the middle
class and all that will be left is a few
people at the top lots of people at the
bottom through technology through
globalization that's a bleak vision of
the future the more pleasant vision of
the future is we will get back to a more
reasonable income distribution not
through massive government intervention
limiting competition limiting outside
entry and limiting the growth of
technologies but by improving people's
endowments by improving the quality of
education by improving capabilities
and tying education and capabilities
more to the kinds of jobs that are being
produced by the economy if we go that
route we can still have a vibrant
capitalism but also an extremely vibrant
democracy with all the tools the social
media etc that we have so those are the
two alternate alternative visions of
course there many more in between so let
me stop there
and give you a chance to ask a few
questions